Israeli air strikes have targeted areas
close to villages in southern Lebanon
missiles were fired at Hezbollah
positions near kafar Shuba Israel has
evacuated towns along the border with
Lebanon after repeated exchanges of fire
Zod reports from Southern
Lebanon Israel's military says it's
targeting Hezbollah positions across the
border in Lebanon it's facing a guilla
war the Iranian back Lebanese armed
group has been attacking Israeli
military positions along the border as
well as tanks using Precision guided
missiles the Waring sides have been
trading
fire along what has been an active front
line since Israel started to attack Gaza
more than a week
ago Hezbollah joined the battle after a
call by its Ally Hamas but it's very
much limiting its response within the
Rules of Engagement established since
its last war with Israel in
2006 Israel says it doesn't want to be
dragged into war on a second front but
it has threatened to respond forcefully
if attacked to engage hisbah in a full
scale War it's it's a very risky thing
it is not popular among the Lebanese uh
population first and it has to have a
green light from the Iranian regime
because that might create new Dynamics
in the Middle East altogether so a
decision of that scale it has to be
cleared by both the Iranian leadership
and maybe syrians as
well Hezbollah has said it's not neutral
in the conflict its backer Iran has
repeatedly warned of a war that would
engulf the whole region if attacks
against Gaza continue but the so-called
axis of resistance hasn't said what
their red line is except that Gaza will
not
fall in other words Hamas will not fall
a decision by Hezbollah to enter the war
with its full military capabilities
could depend on how long its Ally can
sustain Israeli attacks on its
own Iran and its allies across the
region are now focusing their anger on
the US Administration they say it has
given Israel free reign to carry out war
crimes against the Palestinians since
then there have been reports of attacks
on the US military presence in Iraq and
Syria and it exerts on the Americans
additional pressure uh to tell them that
you know if this war happen it will
never it will not be in any way a
conventional War it will have no limits
no borders uh and uh attacks on Israel
and its backers can be from anywhere for
for the time being there is heated
rhetoric while all sides appear to be
weighing the risks and benefits of
Confrontation but what appears to be
shaping up is a protracted crossb War of
Attrition zanah aljaz Southern
Lebanon alaz Ali Hashem joins us from
nura in southern Lebanon even as we keep
an eye screen left on uh the uh scenes
at the Israel Lebanon border where fires
seem to be burning let's see if we can
uh get any information on that with Ali
Ali I don't know if you're in the
vicinity of what I'm seeing but what are
you learning about what's happening at
the border right
now well the border is on fire since
this afternoon several attacks has been
launched in uh different sectors from
the East to the West now we are here on
the West Western sector on the
Mediterranean to the other side the
Eastern sector is on the border with
with Syria and of course Israel so there
have been several attacks just behind me
a few uh hours ago couple of hours ago
the the Israeli posts here positions
here were hit by uh anti- tank guided
missiles from hisbah in accordance there
were uh over 20 Miss Rockets that were
launched by Hamas the Palestinian group
Hamas in Lebanon now uh launching 20
rocket towards Northern Israel and also
there there were bar there was a barrage
of rockets towards Kona to the east U
now we know that there are three people
injured there so a lot of attacks a lot
of uh uh T forat and this also is has
been uh going on as as we know for the
past 10 12 days yesterday in this
morning very early this morning where we
are there were two air strikes and the
loud explosions Israeli airplanes hit
heah targets here in this in this area
and also uh other targets towards the
east so uh the issue is that we are
seeing more attacks on daily basis
before we used to see one two three
attacks today at least there are five
six attacks and now with the this
different uh uh approach given the
rockets that hit a building in Katona
and the reports coming from there that
there are three uh people injured there
this is different this is kind of
changing the situation slightly and
actually uh we've been we've been
watching the uh uh situation gradually
escalating but it seems that we are in a
new phase this is not the same phase
that we witnessed at the first days this
is another phase and there's something I
would like to uh uh emphasize on it
seems also that hasah while attacking
the Israeli posts on the borders they
are kind of uh concentrating on hitting
some communication apparat apparatuses
and tools like um cameras uh uh that are
used to um take the the pictures for the
whole uh borders also communication uh
tools um that are used to intercept
calls and uh this situation so uh there
there are different uh objectives hisbah
is putting in front of them aside from
the war in Gaza aside from the idea of
relieving Gaza from the uh pressure and
trying to draw more enforcements to the
north we can see now after around two
weeks or less a bit less than that from
the beginning of these uh uh these
escalations and this war till the moment
the ground
the ground offensive hasn't start and
this was one of the of the objectives of
hisbah to prevent the ground the ground
offensive and it seems still the moment
the northern front is succeeding in kind
of hurdling the ground
offensive Ali thank you very much for
all of that even as we keep an eye on
the Lebanon Israel border screen left
and I'll keep in mind what you said at
the top of your explanation that the
Israel Lebanon border is on fire and
it's true that since this conflict began
on October 7th uh this round of fighting
there has been tit fortat exchange of uh
artillery fire mortar fire Etc coming
from both sides of the border and that's
why we continue to keep a very close eye
on what's happening there so far
Israel signaling to rather saying to
Lebanon you know warning them not to
enter into a fullscale war Hezbollah has
uh stopped short of that but every day
you explain to us that the Border area
is becoming more and more volatile Al
jaaz is Ali Hashem in nura southern
Lebanon thank you very much